[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión vamos a
falulla en Irak ciudad Que pagó uno de
los precios más altos después de la
invasión de Estados Unidos y sus aliados
a este país hace 20 años el 20 de marzo
de 2003 George Bush puso en marcha la
operación Libertad iraquí para derrocar
al régimen de saddam hussein una
invasión considerada ilegal por Naciones
Unidas y que como hoy sabemos se basó en
una mentira de estado la supuesta
posesión de armas de destrucción masiva
por parte de Sadam hussein armas que
nunca se han encontrado desde entonces
esta guerra se prolongó finalmente hasta
2011 causando la muerte de cientos de
miles de personas y la migración de
millones de iraquíes faluya la ciudad
que en su mayoría apoyaba el Antiguo
dictador Sadam hussein se rápidamente en
2003 en el bastión de una guerrilla suní
opuesta a los estadounidenses hasta
convertirse en el peor enemigo de
Washington la inestabilidad reinante
Durante los años en guerra tuvo
consecuencias mucho más allá del
conflicto que cultivó un terreno fértil
para el yihadismo donde al qaeda en Irak
se dio a conocer antes de convertirse en
daesh en la década de 2010
es imposible que sus habitantes olviden
todos los años de violencia que
cambiaron para siempre el destino de su
ciudad Esta es la historia
Nuestro objetivo de hoy es un miembro de
daesh se encuentra en la región de
alambar en la ciudad de faluya
[Música]
desde su cuartel general estas fuerzas
antiterroristas se preparan para lanzar
una operación contra un iraquí al que
sigue en la pista desde hace casi un año
al parecer el hombre suministra
artefactos explosivos improvisados a los
yihadistas de la región
según nuestra información hay dos
posibles vías de escape y puede ser
alertado en cualquier momento por la
gente del vecindario bueno está claro
chicos
[Música]
estas fuerzas especiales Fueron creadas
por los estadounidenses al comienzo de
la guerra de Irak en 2003
incluyendo faluya donde van hoy
[Música]
se sabía que el distrito de faluya había
sido ocupado por al qaeda después de
sus líderes y miembros fueron
perseguidos allí
muchos han sido asesinados
algunos abandonaron la región pero al
qaeda en Irak se convirtió en daege
los que habían huido se unieron entonces
a dahes y volvieron a las ciudades con
ese nombre
en 2014 el grupo de estado islámico
controlaba esta ciudad y casi el 40% del
territorio iraquín los estadounidenses
no han estado en el país desde 2011 pero
regresan como parte de una coalición
internacional para derrotar al grupo
junto a las fuerzas que crearon 10 años
antes la Victoria está prevista para
pero hoy la lucha continúa de forma
fragmentaria
bien nos estamos acercando a Nuestro
objetivo es un yihadista Así que es
posible que lleve un arma o un cinturón
explosivo
3 de la mañana
esta unidad de élite lanzó la operación
al Amparo de la oscuridad
en una habitación contigo Hay mujeres y
niños se les interroga también
[Música]
tras media hora in situ la operación
llega a su fin
no se encuentra nada en casa lo
sospechosos son detenidos serán
interrogados en Bagdad y luego juzgados
estas fuerzas especiales se consideran
garantes de la estabilidad en el país
los que impiden que daesh se
reconstituya hoy en día siguen contando
con el asesoramiento de los
estadounidenses y este apoyo es
Generalmente bien percibido por la
población
sin embargo no podemos olvidar los
últimos 20 años en Irak Durante los
cuales Estados Unidos Fue considerado
durante mucho tiempo el enemigo del país
en particular faluya desde el comienzo
de la invasión estadounidense esta
ciudad de 300.000 habitantes se
convirtió rápidamente en uno de los
bastiones de la resistencia donde los
estadounidenses eran percibidos
mayoritariamente como opresores una
hostilidad particularmente mostrada el
31 de marzo de 2004 ese día el mundo
entero supo situar familia en un mapa
en ese puente hubo un incidente
importante
mercenarios estadounidenses de la
empresa de seguridad privada blackwater
fueron asesinados y colgados del puente
llegué al final del incidente
hoy decir que había matado a
estadounidenses en la ciudad
al principio muchos se sorprendieron y
se preguntaron Cómo han acabado los
estadounidenses en faluya es una locura
nunca pasaban por aquí porque la ciudad
era muy peligrosa
entonces recuerdo muy bien ese día
Amén aquí vivía entonces en el barrio
fue uno de los primeros testigos de este
acontecimiento
y las imágenes del mismo No tardaron en
difundirse por todo el mundo
mostraba a iraquíes jubilosos
arrastrando los cuerpos calcinados y sin
vida de estos mercenarios por las calles
de la ciudad hasta donde fueron
ahorcados imágenes insoportables que
conmocionaron al mundo
fue un punto de inflexión
un momento histórico para la ciudad
porque a partir de Entonces hubo muchas
más guerras más desgracias más
calamidades
[Música]
ese día el ejército estadounidense
hizo de faluya su objetivo prioritario
salud ya se ha convertido en su enemigo
número uno de todo el mundo Sí después
de este incidente la ciudad se ha
convertido en algo diferente de lo que
era antes
a continuación la ciudad fue bombardeada
por la Aviación y la artillería
estadounidense y las calles se
convirtieron en escenario de
encarnizados combates en los que los
soldados se enfrentaron a los
insurgentes en esa época ame aquí empezó
a escribir poesía como una catarsis para
no volverse loco
Por qué nos ama la muerte
por qué todos los días hay un funeral en
nuestra puerta
Porque todo lo que pedimos en este mundo
se vuelve tan violento solo para
encontrar nuestro cuello
conozco ciudades que estaban llenas de
vida pero ahora sólo vagan fantasmas
desde entonces amed Nunca ha dejado de
escribir
la historia de faluya es muy dura
intento hablar de ello hablar de muchos
acontecimientos aunque no puede hablar
de todo porque las cosas han sido muy
difíciles aquí pero la destrucción y la
muerte que experimentamos a diario deben
documentarse
y uno de los servidores de esta
documentación uno de los ayudantes de la
historia entre los árabes es el poeta
esta Trágica historia fue escrita
principalmente por los insurgentes de la
ciudad
que lucharon sin tregua contra los
estadounidenses que ha sido de ellos
se unió la mayoría a grupos terroristas
encontramos el rastro de uno de ellos
que accedió de forma anónima y en un
lugar secreto a contarnos su historia
estuve en el ejército en 2003 cuando los
estadounidenses invadieron el país
desmantelaron el ejército así que me
quedé sin nada entonces recibimos una
llamada de Sadam husein para defender el
país las tribus llamaron a las armas por
la tierra y por el honor todos los
revolucionarios incluido yo seguimos
este llamamiento todos nos unimos a los
grupos de resistencia al principio Es
importante saber que todos llevaban
armas unos iban a buscar material otros
luchaban otros entregaban mensajes
hacían labores de inteligencia pero
todos eran civiles al
qaeda aprovechó Entonces el caos y se
estableció en la ciudad a principios de
2004 algunos Insurgentes se unen al
movimiento otros deponen las armas para
mí la resistencia se vendió fue
traicionada cuando al qaeda entró en la
ciudad y trabajó por su cuenta los
verdaderos resistentes retirado no se
unieron al qaeda porque sus miembros
justificaban el asesinato de policías y
guardias nacionales iraquíes nuestros
únicos enemigos eran los estadounidenses
hoy estos antiguos Rebeldes ya no hablan
de su pasado por miedo a que se les
asocie con estos grupos terroristas no
no la mayoría se fueron de Irak o
murieron de todos modos y con los demás
seguimos nuestras vidas Aunque algunos
estén paralizados o discapacitados
intercambiamos Saludos pero eso es todo
todo este periodo ha dejado una profunda
huella en la población de faluya
casi dos décadas después las heridas del
pasado siguen abiertas
especialmente para los civiles que
también pagaron un alto precio en los
violentos y a veces indiscriminados
combates
no es algo igual divertido
cubasi perdió la pista de su padre el 10
de noviembre de 2004 demasiado viejo
para abandonar la ciudad controlada
Entonces por la insurgencia fue detenido
en su casa por los estadounidenses los
soldados se llevaban a todos los hombres
de la ciudad sin distinción
junto con su hermano Abdul Moreno seguía
Buscando el cuerpo de su padre casi 20
años después sin muchas esperanzas
se sabe que fue trasladado a la prisión
de bucad
tras haber estado recluido durante un
tiempo en la prisión de abu grave
entonces le perdimos la pista
un día nos pidieron que lo visitáramos
Así que fuimos a Boca pero allí nos
dijeron que estaba en abu drive y
viceversa
todos estos años hemos buscado en todos
los institutos forenses en todos los
cementerios hemos preguntado a las ong
pero nadie sabe dónde está mi padre
según un informe de la Cruz Roja
publicado en 2004 entre el 70 y el 90%
de los prisioneros fueron detenidos por
error por los estadounidenses en aquella
época es una desaparición forzada del
cuerpo de mi padre
solo queremos saber qué pasó Si está
muerto den en su cuerpo y si aún está
vivo libéranlo
este es también el legado de la guerra
decenas de miles de habitantes siguen
buscando respuestas hassan El guardián
de este cementerio de todos los meses
entrar y salir a estas familias
desesperadas
todas estas líneas corresponden al
desconocidos son más de 1200 muchos
murieron en las calles de faluya sus
cuerpos estaban demasiado mutilados sus
zorros toros y reconocibles y no
llevaban consigo ningún documento de
identidad se ha pedido a todas las ongs
y al gobierno que averigüen Quiénes son
estos desconocidos que hagan pruebas de
ADN pero no se ha hecho nada no el
gobierno nunca ha estado aquí
varias fuentes de las autoridades
iraquíes nos dijeron que no se había
hecho nada en los últimos años porque
entre las víctimas podía haber
yihadistas
un asunto demasiado sensible e imposible
de justificar según ellos Aunque en
faluya más de 3500 muertos habrían sido
no combatientes
tras todos estos años de violencia Cómo
pueden reconstruirse sus habitantes
privados de respuestas Y sobre todo de
Justicia como en el pasado a menudo
dependen de sí mismos Todas las semanas
se organizan lecturas de poesía en esta
ciudad
amed aquí está implicado y ahora insiste
en superar las heridas de los últimos
años
[Música]
el arte como remedio uno de los únicos
que han encontrado estas personas para
intentar reconstruirse después de todos
estos años
aquí el poeta tiene un impacto en el
público en los demás Por eso pedimos
vida y amor en nuestros textos de hoy
por la paz muy pocos de los poetas que
escuchamos hoy tratan sobre la muerte y
las armas y todo esto repercute en los
demás
faluya la Rebelde la mártir podría
llegar a ser la ciudad del amor y la paz
que estos poetas intentan contar hoy
este es el sueño de mucha gente aquí
aunque el camino por recorrer sea
probablemente largo y lleno de
obstáculos
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta desde Irak visitamos
faluya una ciudad que evidencia la
Trágica guerra que causó la devastación
del país recuerde que puede Ingresar a
nuestra página web France 24.com para
ver esta emisión y las anteriores Hasta
pronto